The ATR indicator is one of the most widely used indicators on our prop desk and there's
a good reason for this.
In this video, one of our most seasoned prop traders, Garrett Drinan, will break down the
three most effective ways to use this valuable indicator.
I'm Mike Belafuri and we're one of the top proprietary trading firms located in New York
City and proud to have developed number seven and even eight figure per year traders.
希望你同意,
這就是最高YouTube的頻道
幫助你增加你的股票
Garrett here from the New York City desk
and today we're gonna talk about ATR
so we've gotten tons of requests lately
to do a video on ATR especially after doing the Keltner channel video which was about an indicator
based on ATR and so you can check that out on our channel and so we're gonna we're gonna get a
little nerdy today there's some really great stuff here rooted in statistics but also super basic
and directly applicable to trading whether you're a model builder a systems trader or a fully
一個強烈品名就是推廣,它是很重要的。
在這個影片中,你會知道
什麼是,
如何最多的投資人在 our Desk,
用ATR每天前來投資的第一天,
而且我希望大家有提到有趣的想法
如何使用 it。
再到這個影片中,我們會講一下
三个人的实用选择
这种课题是用选择的
专业的课题
首先,我们进入这个课题
要解释了解释的
什么ATR是
和什么重要的
ATR是
几乎的几乎
它是代表的
借购的借购
这是最重要的
它是一部分的经验
我们的经营有些方法,
有些方法,你能够试图的
股票,但这就是很简单的方法。
基本上,看来,看来,
它是在这里的量度,
所以在这里,你能看到高和低,
而在ATR,基本上,是在这里的量度,
是在这里的量度和加上的量度。
所以,一小说,
一位华企业的华企业,他叫 Tim,
他昨天说他有点好在谈到他的依赖友,
人们没关系了,他在谈到我说,
他在谈到这种情感觉,
因为他与他们聊天的时候,
他们在谈论提论的息子,
在谈到股市和股市秘密的移动,
他在谈启书说,他们说,
我说,你与你打开, Tim?
当然他们对他们的货币是对他们的货币人知道他才不知道什么
他就只能把这些货币的货币说明他就不会说明他在中国上有任何货币
那么就这样就像是在我们的货币的货币有我们的货币在我们就在多数的时候
我们在做什么都会认为这个货币的货币是做出的货币是在什么
在每个月的货币的货币上了一项目的货币就能稳定
specifically how this is developed so it's the average range between each bars high and low
over a specific number of periods so on the right here is the actual formula and you can pause the
screen and kind of write this down you could go into your trading platform and any trading platform
is going to have an atr indicator um you know i use one right on thinkorswim and if you look into
the code this is basically what it's going to be doing and it's the true range which is the max of
the high minus the low or the high minus the previous close or the low minus the previous close
and that's basically saying the range of the candle including any gaps that come from the
previous candle and then you just take the average of that over a time period okay so like i said any
每一步的距離方法都可以用這個
你可以用這個在任何時機
例如,在一個一-minute調
在一-minute調,是一-minute距離的一-minute距離
在這個講題裡,我們會主要主要用這個距離的距離
是一個距離距離的距離距離
而是一個距離距離的距離距離
所以,一件事是我們前面的主要說
对这种种程式使用我们能够理一下,
其实它就是公平的原因,
因为我们在这个界线上的设计 例如非常好 流氓的反应。
我们在平均上可以比较相互和相互相互数 。
我们在这些设计方式作为打击到与其他方向的投资予的并渠现了一种?
如果用ATR去平均乱,我们会把一个公司的公司的公司
比较高的公司的公司
这就是非常非常用适当我们的公司和不同的公司
和不同的公司
所以,例如,一$5的公司的公司
基本上是一$1的公司
是非常优秀的公司
while the same $5 move on a stock with an ATR of $10 would be less notable.
By comparing a stock's current price movement to its ATR,
you're effectively normalizing its movement relative to its typical behavior.
And this allows traders to gauge the significance of a price movement more accurately. So by normalizing using ATR, traders can compare movements on a relative scal試動力量甚至是用力駛和不同的价格
或者不同的物質
就是一小比普通通用
就是要来解放
Tesla會有很多大量ATR
因為特朗普通過
普通通過
如果特朗普通可以用 $10
Ford is going to have like a 25 cents ATR
and that represents how much more on average
and this is daily, these are daily ATRs
how much more on average Tesla moves than Ford
so not only is Tesla a higher priced stock than Ford
but it also makes larger percentage moves on average
so this is kind of a no brainer
like we know Tesla is going to move more than Ford
but sometimes it's more subtle
so something like Berkshire Hathaway
BRK,是一額高市值的,
在3.60元的,
在4.40元的,
$4.40元。
像AMC,是一額高市值的,
在11元的,
在4.50元的,
所以,BRKB是一額高市值的,
他們每次都差不多同樣的ATR,
在在4.50元的,
所以这就是在平均上的一天,他们在平均上的一天,
所以这就是一天,一个ATR可以说我们的一天,
如果我们看这些 stocks,我们可以看到
一个市场可以在平均上的一天,不需要有一个大量ATR,
而一个市场可以在平均上的一天,不需要有一个大量ATR。
there are three ways to normalize using ATR
so we can compare the stock to itself
so we can say this stock today is moving three times as much as it usually moves
that's how we can measure that using ATRs to move three ATRs off the open
is something that we might say
we can compare stocks across the market
multiple stocks, we can compare stocks to each other
那是像我们刚才做的,对于车上的车上,
如果我们看一样的公司,我们可以说,
你会说,你会说,
Google只移动两ATRs,
而 Microsoft只移动一,
我们不需要计算,
什么是最高的价值,
这ATR就移动了这种移动
到最简单的比较简单 possible.
然後我們可以加上測試的指標
這就是比較有一點點的,比較有一點點
我們不會再加進去的資料
但基本的概念是
一種指標的指標,或是一種的指標
是一種的指標的指標,
當然是指標的指標,
所以你可能會有很高的指標
that moves a lot feeding information into an indicator like you know an RSI, MACD, like whatever
it is and that indicator might act quite a bit different because it's a higher price more volatile
stock that's feeding information into it so if you're interested in normalizing the activity of
that indicator across stocks you might actually use ATR instead of price movements okay and so
Tim Masters is a really smart algorithmic trading expert.
He has a great book called Statistically Sound Indicators for Financial Market Prediction.
He said,and this just speaks to how important ATR is,he says,how do we measure price volatility for scaling?
There are an infinite number of choices,but my own favorite is average true range,which I believe best reflects
true market volatility for scaling most indicators.
So he likes ATR for this.
There are other things that we can use to normalize movements in stocks,
stuff like standard deviation, which is great, but that's a crazy formula.
I mean, who the hell knows how to write that formula?
We're all traders.
We want simple tools that speak directly to the goal we're trying to achieve,
and ATR does this really well.
所以,大家可以進入了一些例子,
例如昨天,
在用了這件事
所以,
雖然這些都是在這件事
我看了,
這就是了這個人的 trade
我們就進入了一些這些
有三個方法要用ATR
一種方法,
你可以用他們的接受
你可以用他們
接受受受接受
接受受到負責
所以,這就是
what we're going to go through here with some examples so here's AFRM this is a daily chart
and this is yesterday yesterday's close okay so you can see three days ago it had a big breakout
and that was earnings so big volume big breakout and then an inside day the next day and then day
three a continuation breakout right and at the firm will call this a day three breakout where
where it breaks above the earnings day high
after an inside day.
And there was a good amount of volume on this day,
but nothing compared to day one.
But this is a pretty good textbook
day three breakout pattern that we're gonna look at.
And so often when something like this goes off the open
and we're in it, right?
We bought that breakout.
We wanna know, you know, where can I expect this to go?
Like, where can I start to look to take scales, right?
所以用ATR是一方式,我们会看一样的标准,
对吧,什么是一方式的地方,
我们可以做这些地方,我们可以做一个大量ATR,我们可以拆开一个大量ATR,我们可以拆开一个大量ATR,我们可以拆开一个大量A入我们的照片我们认识看是1ATR我们全部扩上去我们的圈谷创线
给我们来的价值
那会让我们来得到这个地方
可以的地下来
1ATR 最后来的价格
1ATR 再多
When它购买1 hour
1日趷值
那是一很好的動作
一件事要留意的確是
在更多的方法,
更多的可能性
它會 surpass一ATR
可以做過多數量的ATR
所以在一天一動作
我們可能會要看一半,兩,三ATR
在一天三動作,
一種少量度,
我們可能會只要看一ATR
像 AFRM did
在外面的開放
所以就像在一种比较多,就看了看,
看了看,你可能会有什么样的。
然后,一个东西可以做,是用了ATR trailing stop。
这是一个不同的 concept,
它是一个方式的方式,
一个方式的方式,
是一个提供的方式,
你能够得到任何方式,
我认为 Thinkorswim它和其他方式,
所以这就是什么它看起来
这个是一个指导的使用ATR
它看起来是一个扫养的扫养
一个扫养的扫养
在这个时候,三个扫养的扫养
所以这就是三个扫养的扫养
从最低扫养的扫养
它是扫养的扫养
the great part about this is that as we know ATR adjusts for the volatility of the stock so the more volatile the stock the looser the stock
if the stock gets more volatile the ATRs will adjust for that and it'll start to get priced into the indicator
and if volatility contracts the same thing will happen and the indicator will get tighter and tighter
它是很棒的方法,如果你有 trouble在一 trade,用一ATR trailing stop,
它可以保持你在一旦比你更多,如果你不用它,
你可以玩到不同的設定,
你能看這一個三ATR,三-period trailing stop,
你能看到它是一位一ATR,只要是一位一ATR,
here's another example from yesterday pdd had earnings and this was a day one earnings and this
exploded off the open on a lot of volume and if you remember earlier i said that when a stock is
doing multiples of average volume we're going to give it a little bit more room to go because
volume is like fuel so especially with a with an earnings catalyst and a lot of relative volume
所以我们将来1ATR应该说一几个好一个在一块
如果它是确实上它是分析一个好一块
所以PDD会7出来
那第一个大约1ATR是1.5
这就是1.5%的一条
但是你跟他的部位出现
你会有配合设计
你会找到你的设定
他们每个人的价格都则1ATR
那是一位你也想要去打算
你可能会看到你会有很大的热烈
在业务的业务上的业务上
你会看到你会有2ATR或是3ATR
你会有多多的业务的
这些都是例如我们可以看这些开放的
在开放的开放
然后再看一看,
好,这些是什么
同时,我们就在看到这些人的看法。
我们的评论,移动了一段时间。
同时,我们的三个一-minute bar ATR, 从最后的三个人的关系。
我们的同时,它会在推出一个同时,然后,它会在排出一段时间。
好了, here's PDD on the same day, we're just zooming out a little bit, and we've drawn
a pre-market level that was a pretty significant level in the morning before the open.
And if you were trading this and you were kind of buying it like off the open, say like
on the first candle, and you wanted to put a stop below this significant pre-market level,
你可能会把这些高度的高度
但你也可能会给它一种更多的地方
因为我们知道
我们的 stocks喜欢在这些高度的高度
然后在这些高度的高度
所以如果我会在这些高度的高度
我认为这些高度的高度
我会有些高度的高度
我会在这些高度的高度
我真的想要看它高度的高度
我会不会只要放到高度的高度
在那一層的高度上,
因為我會在那層的高度上,
特別是931,932,
那是真的什麼事,
所以,一件事你能做,
是你能用它的日常ATR
是一個重點,
你能用一百分的那一層
並且伸到那層的高度上,
所以,它是給它們的高度上的高度上,
如果你是在文字上,如果你是在文字上,
你会知道,在某些程度上,
这就是很好的课程,
你可以用ATR去 inform
到某些程度上,
你能够购买不同的课程,
你能够用ATR去平均的距离,所以这个PDD的课程是会有一定的级,所以在这个时候10%的大约的ATR是这个PDD的高度是有一定的线所以在这个时候10%的日子的低线是会员10%的低线的平线
所以如果做这个CMG的高价值
这会是在1000的高价值
这会是一个比较高的距离
but relatively speaking it's going to give it an appropriate distance from that stop.
And again, like if you're trading a really low price stock,
it's going to do the same thing where it might actually just give you a few pennies.
Okay, so it's a great way to adjust that space if you're trading a lot of different tickers.
All right, and here's our third example. This is VFS from yesterday, and this was an over extension play.
You can see it went five days in a row as volume started to come into the stock.
這裡有一個可以做的ATR
去給一個測試的測試
在每個月的超過測試
在每個月的測試
你可以想想想
好,這麼多的時間在五個月
所以在這個時候
如果有四個月的ATR
在五個月的五個月
你會得到那一塊月的
這就是一個月的
這就是一個月的測試
如果有一個月的設置
可以回到,可以看,好多久,都要去看,
我可以用5,这个一半,很近,很近,
但是这些是好多,他们是好多,只是要去看,
如果它只能到3,你能知道,你会知道,
那是不宗耐的,以为我所拥有的例子,
和我所拥有的领域的领域,
就像是1日,1日,1日就能看到了比例,
这就是一个游戏的游戏,
我们问一下,
每天ATR,每天ATR,有这些价值的价值在5天?
你将下来的高从5天后的数据,
你将下来的数据,在这一切业的高,
在这个时候4.5%的高,
它是供应率的,它是供应率的,
它是供应率的,
然后,有些人的书,
有些人的书,
也有一个人的书,
这些书是一个公平的书,
我们在一个公平的书,
我们在书,
因为这些书,
这些书是书,
如果您想看这个书,
我们可以在书上的书,
所以你看,你能看到这个评论可以用在很多情况下,
如果你想要建设定的权利用来的权利用,
这个是一种手术的权利用,
如果你是一种完全的创业,
可以做出的创业,这个可以用来做出的一种关系。
所以,在最最后,
它是一种方式的方式的方式,
所以如果你想要解决的接触,
或者是一种方式的方式,
我会把你的投资方法的交流
是一种方法的方法
所以请按下留言
我会给你解答的
我们喜欢你如何用ATR
我会用你投资的方法
你会用你的投资方法
把我的投资方法都给你
是什么给你这个公司的方法
你可以追我投资方法
在下面的影片中, 讓你來看
一年一月
我去我的 office
所以我可以分享更多
你可能会看到
一些浪费
划流量
费用轮廓
一天
甚至 15分钟
然后
他们在游戏
在一个游戏的游戏
在一天
我可以告诉你
我们的费用轮廓
像是
跑选择
他们活动
和继续
在我企業,我們在我們的業務之中
我們有它需要這次的決定
在這遊戲的表面
我是一個大家的割
副副創作者和主管的
雙倍副創作者
一面的最多經驗局
在我們香港裡的我們
我們一直在賠資金
找來找來找的
不只為我們在你的樓上
返的地方
我們在它的家裡
我們來找這一家
我們有新的資料都做的
讓他們去做了7個月的資料
在負責到負責到負責任的資料
但是要求能力的資料
你需要有這個資料
這就是為了我們做一個新的訓練
我們分享會如何能夠成為
SNB成為一個資料的資料
負責責責任利責責任責任
和獲得到所有資料的資料
and resources. And the best part, you don't have to be a profitable trader yet. In fact, we prefer to
mold profitable traders with our methods and our techniques. That's why we have just three simple
criteria that can earn anyone an interview. We're looking for highly ambitious and determined
traders who fit our culture first and foremost. So if you believe that could be you, sign up for
the free one hour online presentation by clicking the link that's in your top right corner of your
screen now